all right hot breath averse welcome back
to the hot breath podcast I am your host
comedian Joel Byers this is the show
where you learn comedy from the pros if
you're interested in getting involved in
more of these QAS go to our Facebook
group search hot breath comedy Network
and you can start getting involved in
more q and A's
but today's guest his resume would
require the entire show linked so let's
just bring him in give it up for the one
and only Tommy Davidson ladies and
gentlemen welcome him to the hot breath
averse thought I was Ellen oh yeah I've
heard that before I've gotten that
before
I'll take her money for sure yeah that
was actually my wife she roasts me and
that's one of her favorite roasts is
saying that I look like Ellen so you're
in good company that's is it that I
think she just wants the money is that
her so what I want to jump into first
here is as I'm adjusting the banner here
this is actually our second time doing
zoom so I'm being very professional and
[Music]
so we're jumping baby and I want to jump
right into your book because this is for
people listening Kevin Hart released a
book a few years ago that a lot of
comics were talking about I feel like if
you're a comedian or a comedy fan
as a comedian this is a must this should
be on your essential reading list
because the journey not only takes us
from I mean just being a baby that was
found in the dumpster to becoming a
entertainment superstar yes it's called
living in color and we will have links
to all of that into the descriptions but
what I enjoyed most about it
was getting into your mindset around
being a student of the game which is
what this whole shows about being a
student of comedy and it was fun to hear
you talk about coming up with Chris Rock
and him opening for you but then also
you performing between Richard Pryor and
Eddie Murphy at the Comedy Store but the
one I want to jump into is your
experience performing with Jim Carrey on
in living color because you you were
talking about it would take him like
four hours to like do a sketch and he
was his attention to detail and you two
were just so magnetic in scenes together
so could you take us into more detail
about the experience just working with
him one on one and seeing his process
and how it affected yours and your
overall journey okay basically he was
because he made you stick around for
four hours your stuff is our stuff is
our stuff we all know what we're doing
and we all love to work together and
stuff like that but Jim actually worked
on another level he was more you know
very Picasso like about what he was
doing you know anybody who does said in
any any field you know reaps the success
on another level and I was I was really
a beneficial to to to witness it but not
only that but it was just fun it was
just fun because the payoff was big the
payoff was the funniest stuff you ever
want to see and so you know like
everybody like every cast member on that
show I learned something from
the thing that I learned from him was
just his persistence to get the right
result the persistence get the right the
result in the right was always like
something like crazy that you could have
thought of ever and his career pretty
much parallels that because look at the
you know the variation of movies that he
done and the variation of things that
he's done it Springs out of that type of
thinking and that's the one thing that
turned me on about being in that
atmosphere and in terms of like in a
detail cuz you're using a scale and
studying else what else what else what
else are on there's an echo on you oh
it's my audio on your computer yeah see
oh no I didn't know if the echo is from
your computer yeah but is it still let
me start talking and no promise your
fall oh yeah oh it's always the white
man's fault come on now I'm white and
woke here I know I know
tik-tok for us and another thing I
wanted to get into before we get into
the questions here is you talking about
your relationship with Sinclair Jones
and how he had a very linear 10-year
plan for your success and it all played
out as someone who's now 10 years into
my career and now looking to start
planning like specific things like what
did that game what did that plan
actually look like and how were you
executing it on every step of the way it
was real specific okay it was okay
jot it down on paper where do you see
yourself in five years where do you see
yourself in ten years
you see yourself in 15 years and where
do you see yourself in 20 years then
everything that you want to accomplish
in linear order so the first five years
was to be coming it actually happened
faster than 20 it happened by 15 maybe
maybe maybe even 12 but you know
stand-up comedy to become a nationally
known stand-up comic first and foremost
and a good one a good one how do you
become a good and what's good no I mean
like oh this you know because comic
perception right no comedy is technique
comedies techniques so you become a good
comic is to be able to do all the things
basic to what a comic does in function
you know so able to present your point
of view able to deliver that able to
deliver it in atmosphere where there's a
lot of distractions able to come up with
your ideas able to list your ideas okay
and have them executed okay you can work
abstract through their ideas but if you
want to get to the point where you want
to present your ideas as a stand-up
comic you're gonna have to take those
ideas that you have and put them in
order in order to put them into a time
frame to shoot a special or to do comedy
that's ready for TV your comedy is ready
for TV then you can go to that next
level maybe even film you know a
stand-up film but this is stand-up
comedy we're talking about you see so to
become a nationally known stand-up comic
there's a lot of other stuff involved in
just then just your act how do you do
that you know you work at clubs you were
consistently at clubs it changes it's
changed over time because we didn't have
internet no you know you become a
comic and you get no you can't get
nationally-known unless you're playing
comments around the country so if you're
not able to play comics around the
country what are you supposed to do
right well you probably would go to the
part of the country that supports that
business if I was a dairy farmer I
probably would do better in Wisconsin
than in El Paso Texas you know because
that's dairy country so what does comic
country weird all the opportunities for
the comics New York and LA so putting
your face in the place gives you that
next potential of becoming national and
then there's all these other subsidiary
businesses that are involved as
management there's agency publicity was
all those things but it all comes down
to your act because hey when you get all
that attention and you do become
national it would be good to have an act
hmm you know but not just have an act it
it would be really good to have an act
that's really good now that's kind of
changed with the internet because you
don't really have to have an act that's
really good all you gotta do is have a
bunch some people push your button that
says like see whether they like it or
not mmm they push that button then you
can get a million million million likes
on something there really ain't that
funny but it looks like a lot of people
like it
because there's the system well me ins
could like it and then then the people
that make things happen go he's the one
we want you know what I mean or she's
the one we want but a comical look at
her you'll go wait a second he's reading
a poem on a toilet by taking the crap
funny about that I mean yes yes yes yes
yes you're sitting in front of
elementary about stand-up comedy
stand-up comedy you're standing up in
front of people who don't know you more
than 10 usually you know and they're
looking right at you and they all are
from different backgrounds
and I have a very very good mind and
values and morals you have to make them
all laugh at the same time over and over
again you see so if I come off the
internet and I never heard of laughs but
I'm only getting someone to push a
button that says like and if you don't
laugh I might think you don't like me no
but you say you say that you say in your
book that you say in your book that
particular makes it Universal it makes
it universe and that's how you've been
able to entertain so many different
diverse audiences so what do you what is
that particular well that particular is
just being able to understand the nature
of things and being able to convey that
to a group of people okay
like you know for instance you know
we've all seen a dog right most people
by that time by the time they're at the
club they've seen a dog you know but do
they know a difference between a dog
that bites or not okay this is comedy
okay right I'm showing you the
particulars right so I'll give you my
experience on a dog that bites and a dog
that does them so I'll give you my take
all right I think that a dog that
doesn't bite is the one that acts like
it bites okay cuz this is bad it's got
its in its bark so the dog that doesn't
bite gotta give you more work to
convince that he's a biter
so usually a dog that bites
okay that is a dog then looks like it
might okay uh-huh
all right you can see you see how much
is going into the bark you see that
yeah yeah he's trying to convince me I
could even break his pattern I just kind
of want to come over here you can break
the pattern so it's showing the audience
of the posters telling them also tell
you about a dog a dog that does bite
doesn't have to work it knows it bites
you have to find out usually a dog that
bites doesn't bark at all cuz he doesn't
wanna bite you cuz you know he can't
help it and you know he'll most likely
get hurt
this makes the hell out of here so he'll
try to kind of warn you as you walk over
I'll bite you
actually a dog that bites kind of talks
kind of tries to let you know hey man
you bout to get bitten sorry as I walk
up on a dog that bites he doesn't bark
he more kind of talks easy between
saying I talked that by stasi you look
at you he looks out the way okay cuz
it's hoping you don't come on
it might look for a second to see what
he's gonna bite ran Steve stand out I I
showed you something essential something
that everybody knows about a dog and
took you into a intricate similarity
that everyone knows maybe not
intellectually but innately and
instinctually you see stand-up is more
than it then more than it action looks
like looks like you get up - hey man
yeah
you know my cousin dog was walking down
a street one day and that about after
that and I don't it's not really that
there so there's so many dimensions of
it you know another one of the
dimensions is Santa see I gave you Sarah
hey dog dog bites which dog bites this
dog
by that dog Dubai get it math cetera so
becoming that comedian and that's
different for everybody
you know Dave Chappelle starting
somewhere Chris Rock started somewhere
Eddie Murphy started somewhere Richard
Pryor started somewhere with box started
somewhere sorts Carlin started somewhere
you know and usually the places that
they started other places that I started
mm-hmm so I'm really lucky I started at
the Comedy Store
let's talk about fact I started um
people can get mad at me but I started
at @d clubs I started to catch a rising
star in New York I started you know I
love comedy act theater comedy act
theater there you go Steve the guy is
black okay although if you looked at him
at the outset for a couple of seconds
and looks like Ellen when you first see
him you know I mean trust me yeah
worried for he kind of looks like just a
little bit when you see him Ted Koppel
but that no you might want to Google
anything so so so so who's up yeah hi
I'm Ted Koppel and welcome to Nightline
[Music]
so we all are kind of related but five
years took three mmm see to get across
the country to a place where they did
comedy to hone it and to finally get a
television show like him in color which
is going to increase my stand-up
disability see mm-hmm and two birds with
one stone
stand-up TV that was the next five years
see was to become a major TV star so
that came together which eventually led
to doing a movies so a year after I was
doing in living color I did my first
movie strictly business was followed by
10 10 11 12 13
there's the movie part you know after
that directing writing authoring
producing back to duck a deer that is a
female deer ray a drop of Golden Sun or
Martin Lawrence's sister her name is Ray
Lawrence me that's the name I call
myself right far a long long way to come
with racism in America right
I don't know what's so let him use yeah
so I guess we um we reap to some right
la right is like Slick Rick lottie
dottie we like to party we don't cause
trouble we don't earn any money we're
just the men that's on the mic we rock
the house rock out right that's him and
Dougie fresh and I'm it all goes back to
Joe which none of us have because I'm
what's going on with all all right let's
get into some fan questions yes sang by
a very skinny white chick you know
really really beautiful okay yes
so dose God I'm talking to you I thought
I forget I forgot that I'm talking to a
post-millennial go ahead I know your
time out sound of music music I know I'm
talking about you I almost forgot I was
talking to a post maleeni Oh
post-millennial oh yeah yeah we out you
I look 12 but I'm trying to there's only
that much of a gap between you guys and
the gap is you know what in living color
is and both of you guys know who
yes and the first question is actually
about in living color in living color
it's it is from a Robin Sutton Clark who
asks so what was your audition process
for in living color and did you think it
would grow as a big cult following as it
did when you first signed on for it my
audition was terrible terrible to me and
I I didn't even want to do the show I
turned the show down and that had to do
with just a lot of disappointments that
had happened to me previous to getting
getting an offer to do the audition no
don't let things keep you from taking
chances and I almost did that my agent
talked me into going in auditioning for
this show that changed my life I mean so
I I was asked to do improv when I first
went in and I didn't know what improv
was although I I've been doing it all my
life and had never been pointed out to
me she never wins the executive producer
and the his partner tomorrow it and the
casting put me through a whole you know
maze of different scenarios you know
your Porter where you can cabdriver and
you're drunk and you want to matter your
cab I know I'm going to take you nowhere
because I so they were like okay thank
you
there was no like yay laughing in the
room but but they had a stand-up comedy
audition thirty of the hottest comics in
LA at the time Jim Carrey you name them
we're all there I went on last and I was
happy but Happy's men you could ever
find because I'm like
Michael Jordan okay
I practiced so hard it comes natural I'm
like Bruce Lee okay
I practice so hard it comes natural
I experience a natural natural is an
unnatural naturalness and I'm last so I
stay on outside and I don't watch any of
the communities because I don't want
anything in my head but what I'm
thinking you know and I go on stage kill
it
not easily but with what I know and I
got a standing ovation and Kenan said
you got the show and it was a very proud
moment for me actually we all got
together to do the show and I saw all
all the people that I was doing the
clubs with Jim David you know Damon I
mean all the bad asses were on the show
and we knew we knew this thing everyone
gets on the air it's over over it's like
taking a team weave with Tom Brady you
know Lynn Swann taking an all-star team
in see him what do you think they'll do
in the aim what do you think I felt you
don't name we knew it was gonna happen
but it took a long time to happen
we didn't think it ever to get on the
air I mean when me and Jim saw each
other we like oh God working together
you know what I mean yeah man yeah man
he was crazy and I think I have
questions yeah you did you nailed it it
actually kind of mellowed into the night
actually kind of working for the next
dream team when we're thinking you make
sense you're mixing now he were Aaron
Aaron nice I'm to cook I'm taking like
I'm I'm Ted Koppel okay
Yoshii so asks can you the Wayans and
Jim Carrey do a review a anytime you
guys want us to I'll text mine um I'll
text them yeah yeah I'll cinnamon tea um
yes that's digging for gold babe all
right if no one ever ate boogers and how
does everybody know they're salt anyway
okay so so so so right so I forgot the
question it was can you the way was you
here you the rains and Jim Carrey do
reunion that would be really fun yes we
can will we I don't know but I do
believe now this is subjective I do
believe that we will I think it's
inevitable I think it's inevitable
I think it's an I think it's necessary
to it's gonna become necessary you know
it's always necessary for Batman to
usually show up after it's all going
down you know I mean well like the
accent you know when it starts getting
too heavy that blackjack comes over man
they'll and beast jumps out you know
storm no Keenen Ivory Wayans comes with
his wheelchair
come on slope you know what I mean you
know coming you know to me mm-hmm
and when we come out of it yeah and it's
time it's time to get down you know I
mean it's it's not gonna be like the
reunion between like Kenobi and Anakin
you know all sets for the Star Wars fans
bye awesome so let's let me jump let's
let's jump channel on here oh he says
Helia that would make me so happy and
people are laughing at Ted Koppel take
those comments with a grain of salt
there ain't a salt there they don't all
know everything
about the guy who asked the question yes
yes he's an alien
he's one he's an alien from the alien
abduction chapter nine that you all have
to get the book no no no I know exactly
who he is he's an alien driving the old
Corvette in the butter cream so he's the
Grey Poupon guy in the limousine you got
no no no he he's he's the guy sitting
next to snoop in the new insurance
commercial he's shacking the Buick at
the Buick oh he missed that one oh my
bombed yes and Tommy Davidson
I know but check it a Buick car
hold on I digress you're right using the
Buick right that's right right that's
right if you want to give you shirts and
save one time I witness big all the time
I didn't see the whole word me neither
Shaq and I love he goes if you want to
shake it book say you want to see me
curse and save some time I was digging
all the time that's where I draw the
line I can't
[Music]
and what happens alright we'll get will
try to get to this many of your
questions just can kids we have a few
more minutes here the next one from June
1 Coulson oh I know but see where
there's a slight delay so then like
we'll jump like we're trying to play
double dutch but we each only have one
leg right and I'm looking for an
immediate response as a comic you want
that oh yeah for sure
oh and oh I don't get always what I want
but I'm here for you Tommy but I'm I'm
here all right I'm here
so the next one this is a good one yard
from the season passes over the years
what has surprised you most about the
entertainment industry most about the
entertainment industry how mediocrity
has been accepted as a norm
everything went down it was a mediocre
answer Hey the dog's foot was stuck in
anyway so yeah the overall mediocrity
hope that wasn't mediocre moment that
was real that was beautiful
I shoulda told my dog here but he's with
my wife let's move on to the next one I
go wasn't that classic yeah I I actually
didn't think there was a dog I thought
you were just now doing a bit about a
crying dog verse like a not crying guys
[Music]
so back to a little stand up here this
is from trainer Steve he says in terms
of skill when did you see your biggest
jumps as a comedian and what do you
attribute to those jokes you attribute
to those jokes comparing my stuff to
others that I will see not comparing my
stuff not to make my material but
comparing my technique I came up in the
comedy store
when Roseanne was cutting her teeth when
sent when Adam Sandler was setting his
teeth when Seinfeld was cutting his
teeth when I mean you can just knit you
name them all in the main room and up in
the Bailey room in a small room over at
the Comedy Store and
laughing and watching these people work
a gym when I first got to the gym
watching gym work just watching these
people work you know before they had TV
shows you know Tom Hanks before you know
he was life is like a box of chocolates
you know what I'm saying
watching them before their big success
before Jay Leno was on The Tonight Show
you know as a host when he was a
stand-up doing 10 min five minutes on
there and warming up at the Comedy Store
or Sam Kennedy's him when he first came
to town I reckon going there's this guy
is fat what I do with curly hair man he
is killing it you know and on and on and
on that's when I started looking at the
different things that people were doing
and what they were able to do what
really came to mind for me was I wanted
to understand how I could do how would
it be if I could take a little bit of
every technique him put him into one
technique and that's my stand-up so I
took rudiments of every piece of what I
saw not material okay
no material technique so Carlin's
ability to be able to follow through
with a intellectual idea set it up make
you see it and then get a laugh off of
it Jim Carrey to be able to physically
show you something so so powerful and so
in-depth and so specific that's laughs
Chris Rock being able to take something
political and being able to being able
to put such a shine on it that it is
hilarious and true you know rosanne just
funny about who she is who she is as a
person
okay just watching all these things
Charlie Fleischer was the voice Roger
Rabbit who's a brilliant comedian when I
watched his show and I would watch him
perform you want to go back and read a
book he can take anything and make it
comedy maad of more fascists
you know Japanese Shogun era who does
that
so I was able to rein in all of them and
then express my stuff so I'll take it
I'll make it more simple for the person
who asked the question in martial arts
there's different styles as judo there's
Aikido as karate this can call there's
all these different styles kung fu' you
know and all of them have different
techniques for us to take a small
rudiment or small basic from each one of
them and put them into one art form what
would that be and there's two words
Tommy bees let's land this plane here
let's land this plane here my friends
exactly and so there won't be any delay
and everybody can hear this that is I'm
sorry we're not in Kansas anymore or
Kansas City won the Superbowl
so Negro at quarterback so as some
closing advice here my favorite part
about your book which every one part
about your to go yes like that is a must
read for any comedy fan comedy fan and
comedian because you're also a student
of the case you're also so audiobook I
bought the audiobook if the in case they
don't feel like reading they just wanna
put on the headphones you know I mean
instead of my engine you know on the
boys we just have you seen the boys
a lot of good stuff on TV besides like
promote hours but audiobook - what do
you think about the audiobook we did
that was hard to do I loved it because
you were reading it some people don't
read their audiobook I'm glad you did
okay okay I'm glad you did yeah oh thank
you man thank you
yeah I guess to be known I read it
myself so what a different one address
closing advice for us as a comedian what
advice do I need to hear right well I
studied here right now um never do an
audiobook because it's really hard it's
like taking an aspirin and trying to put
it into wild lions but all with your
hands okay besides that be on stage
don't mess around man be on stage seven
nights a week seven nights per week it's
like wanting to go to the NFL or not
doing a push-up or something no not
being willing to train train seven
nights a week no matter what's what no
matter what city you're in and if it
comes to the parent to you that you
can't do seven nights a week in that
city then go to another city you get
seven nights a week being on the stage
seven nights a week and I believe that
the comedy God will take you right there
hand you start to put stuff in to your
hard drive
well we have a lot of romics well we
have a lot to process
mm-hmm I tell comics that all the time
then the next comment is they go well
besides that
and the real thing I'm saying it is is
that without that you can still be a
stand-up comedy I mean without that
ending stupidest animal comedian but if
you want rate one it's up to you to
really put in the work that it takes to
get to the level where something great
is effortless because you're not doing
it because it's great and you're doing
it because you love it
Tommy Davidson thank you for your time
my favorites and thank you for your time
my friend
thank you do you want to let people know
where they can buy I let people know or
by the follow you support use all that
use or you all that jazz or can I tell
them worry they can't
whether they already know that alright
so Amazon would be the main place to go
the main place to go okay yeah any place
to go you know and if you find a Barnes
and Nobles that's open tell me because
they gotta start by tuning in
alright well hop Bret the verse verse
I'm telling you like him telling you
like all comics life must read
proclaiming there's a game-changer for
me thank you so thank you so much
Tommy Davidson Davidson to be on hot
breath podcast well thank you can soon
my friend we'll see you again soon my
friends yeah and you're in Georgia right
yeah we're in Atlanta
yeah did you enjoy this yeah did you
enjoy this I had a good time yeah
anytime somebody's asking about me I'm
really happy
typical comic and really typical comic
yeah alright well this is definitely a
benchmarking arm well this is Morgan our
and show I'm sure we'll have you back
again sometime anytime you call I'm
there because what I am first all these
things I'm a stand-up comedian
I love it me to my arena
me to my man I'm
I'm on like a Marine I'm only concerned
about three cakes God poor country you
served your duty today my view served
your duty today my friend no I mean
music country music a white joke to
close I get it to close it I get it
come on it's Georgia okay
it's a whole southern Caucasian based
right it's a whole southern Caucasian I
mean not Atlanta sling I mean not
Atlanta where I started comedy I was
like the only white guy um buddy I was
like the only white guy in the zip code
no but I'm just saying in general as a
state mm-hmm yeah we're pretty good
spread we're pretty widespread country
kind of culture you know that is based
in the genocide of the Native American
Indians but I'm not no I'm aware I'm
aware of state of white iron I'm all
lives matter why I offend myself that's
what makes me unique that tell jokes
about sovereign Native American you
could be that guy could be that guy I'm
working on it
all right everyone's saying thanks
everyone say you to be the best thanks
for all the laughs you're the best
thanks you ever best interview ever
yeah a lot of a lot of good feedback
here okay yeah direct and I'll be sure
mm-hmm this is going to this isn't our
faceless Corona
this is gonna be posted on YouTube and
as a podcast I'm trying to make it
talked about this is this is my way area
appreciated the best way in right now
are like the only
that's pretty cool for you guys you know
hey I got a motto for you once you get
to the time interview we'll ask you how
you got to the top and you're gonna say
you wouldn't that mean
[Music]
Thank You Man all right man Tommy
Davidson have a good day buddy thank you
so much man have a good one man
all right you two things not real are
you - thanks
you